e o sol se aguenta mais um vídeo e hoje
eu vou mostrar como é que eu tentei
criar um brinquedo como este aqui
é a primeira coisa que eu fiz foi
comprar um rolamento eu que estou mais
ou menos cinco euros O que é bastante
caro em comparação com isto que custa
5:30 Mas isso é porque usei um rolamento
grande e depois eu percebi que o verão é
que está aqui no meio é bem Pequenino
tem só um centímetro de diâmetro e eu
comprei um rolamento com dois
centímetros de dois de criança então
comprei um rolamento mais quem vai ficar
mais barato e podem também comprar um
rolamento online que fica ainda mais
para você tem que tirar essa proteção a
volta utilizei um x-ato e depois tem que
tirar o óleo que está no meio das
bolinhas para isso podem usar aguarrás
mas quiserem esse o sem proteção
adequada
antes de começar a modelar é muito
importante você saber qual é o diâmetro
da vossa bateria e também do rolamento
para ser bastante fácil de medir vocês
podem arranjar como foi aqui muito como
este aqui foram modelar decidiu utilizar
o Google sketch O que foi o primeiro
programa 3D que eu aprendi e é bastante
intuitivo Então acho que é melhor coisa
que vocês podem fazer é começar com esse
programa e também é gratuito Então
pessoal trabalhar para poder imprimir o
eu pego formato SPL importei para o
programa Ritter fosse que é um programa
gratuito que vocês conseguem baixar
também na internet e aqui o computador
vai fazer os cálculos para dividir a
peça por camadas depois quando os
cálculos tiverem feitos é só carregar e
imprimir
E aí
Oi
[Música]
e a peça já está feita ficou muito bem
eu acho eu usei uma qualidade e pressão
baixa ou seja fiz camadas grossas porque
também não Assim muitos detalhes para
adicionar este o queria em primeiros
rapidamente EA única coisa que eu não
consegui colocar a primeira foi o
rolamento arrumei eu tive que desgastado
ligeiramente utilizando lixa e um lápis
e
E aí
a
iniciativa um pouco dificuldade em
encaixar uma na outra mas foi bastante
simples de resolver isso ativo que
desgastado ligeiramente este fino e
agora já encaixa bem e fica bem preso e
não sei como falsidade
[Música]
E aí
O que é que está o resultado é não ficou
nada de especial em termos de rotação E
isso acontece porque eu estraguei o
rolamento tirei esta coroa que estava
aqui dentro depois voltei o por e quando
coloquei de novo a meio que começou a
criar a 30 que nem interior e já não
gira bem e depois tem um grande problema
é que isto é muito leve as baterias não
tem peso quase nenhum e é muito
importante tenha peso lateral para isto
girar então estou a pensar em fazer
outro e vou tentar fazer uma coisa
diferente que é tentar que o Spinner
Acenda as duas só quando começar a girar
para isso eu vou usar a força em tipo da
e quando começar a girar vai ver umas
tampinhas que eu vou pressionar
controled e desta forma o LED depois vai
contratar bateria e vai ser os agora se
vai funcionar não sei mas vou
experimentar hum
E aí
[Música]
G1
E aí
[Música]
oi oi
bom
[Música]
então se a Sofia eu espero que vocês
tenham gostado a terceira vai sempre vez
o fazer outro vídeo acho ele se estiver
algumas ações e eu vou comprar um
rolamento de novo e eu também posso
fazer isto utilizando as vossas ideias
de design ou seja se vocês ver se vocês
tiverem uma ideia da de uma forma
interessante para isto é só maneira
fotografia para a minha página do
Facebook e eu vou usar isso como
referência para o modelo 3D e isso aqui
também certa fez o pessoal esse aqui até
funciona melhor e esse aqui porque estas
duas extremidades ficam aqui encostados
contra a palma da mão e assim Vocês
conseguem mandar como